ici nous n'avons pas une agriculture
nourricière devant exportatrices vers la
métropole
donc c'est pas un idiot qui qui qui qui
rassemble consommateur et le producteur
la mission première en angleterre c'est
nourrir un peu mais nous oui bien
s'épanouir et avec des principes
économiques possibles économie devenue
que nous avons production artificielle
s'est vite fait avec des bourses
quantité et puis nous connaître ça qui
les problèmes avec le sol avec leurs
collègues une bonne emprise en tournage
en plus nous contaminer toute seule
matinée
donc le vrai la voix mission
agriculteurs c'est une nuit sainement
pop et c'est ça le gros gap le possible
de la souveraineté alimentaire sur le
doigt un peuple d'avoir une alimentation
saine et culturellement produite avec
dépossédé de développement durable je
suis un dingue du biologique
donc ça veut 18 ans mais en disant adieu
goûtu biologique mais on roule pas sur
l'or
donc le plus important c'est que on est
beaucoup plus intéressant à offrir une
alimentation saine à la population
surtout de consommateurs et puis c'est
le contact direct entre producteurs et
consommateurs s'est défait de l'échelle
le randonneur et puis donc sur vos
besoins de l'heure occupée par les
productions
je suis rendu honneur et j'ai une
association de randonnée en sauva soins
j'aimerais bien les emmener ici pour
découvrir un peu la nature faire un
chemin de randonnée avec accent emmener
des randonneurs ici que puis se vend au
moins ce que fait alexandre paley
biologique